show us your medal we need to see that
in person
at the gym where galileo fire learnt his
skills a chance for him to say
thank you from tokyo to his older
brothers and the coach who started him
on the road to gold his brothers are
used to success
cal is a recent world champion and gamal
has won european and commonwealth belts
but they say their little brother's
performance has eclipsed them both
winning world titles is unbelievable but
i just think
winning the winning olympic gold it just
has that something so
just as something else add something
else to it it's just that sound of being
saying olympic champion olympic gold
medalist and
it's just an unbelievable achievement i
could win a world title tomorrow we have
20 million quid in the bank this would
olympic gold tops it all for me and
she's special
for us the whole family for gallau's mum
gratitude for her son's mentor
he took my boys on and they were a
handful
and he got them where they are today and
relief for herself
today with something special i i still
think i'm in shock
i am in shock i think i can't believe
that gallant won a gold medal
i can part of me but i can't believe
it's gala at the pat benson boxing
academy in birmingham today the gloves
are definitely on
the boxers here are all well aware of
gallal's superfly ufi's outstanding
performance in tokyo
as well as the inspiration he provides
absolutely i mean i'm getting like
15 kids coming through the doors now
wanting to be the next future
champion of the sport you know and
obviously with the commonwealth games
coming next year as well i'm getting a
lot of juniors and seniors
through the doors as well hoping that
they can do the same thing following
gala's footsteps it's always good to see
someone from your local
community or even from your place or
your country doing good
younger brother who is around 11
he also wants to start boxing actually
getting a gold medal
from birmingham that is like whoa
it's already been an inspiring and
historic performance by the british
boxers
and with lauren price fighting for
middleweight gold tomorrow
it could get even better as team gb
continues to punch above its weight
fraser moord sky news birmingham